this leads us to what i did to lou so
there's an 11 year old little kid we
drove him at one in the morning to that
building at lou's house i wrote a note
put it in his pocket we messed him up
like made him his we
bought him some clothes at the welfare
place and ripped some clothes and made
them dirty
and then i called lou at one in the
morning knowing he was home he was in
bed
not dressed just wearing his tighty
whities and he uh i called him i go lou
what's doing he goes nothing i just
can't sleep and it and we timed it
perfectly that that kid
knocked at the door he goes to somebody
at my door
at one o'clock in the morning and i fell
for it i fell for it again
that's too you're too early with i fell
for it because a knock at the door
everybody falls forward at one in the
morning you're talking to me on the
phone coincidentally somebody knocks on
the door hang on holly let me see who's
here no there's there's somebody at the
door and he looks through the people he
goes as a child at my door
at one in the morning and i go no
[ __ ] way there's no way you have it
there's a child's at your door he goes
hang on a minute because this is so
weird
and the kid's just looking there and the
kid hands him a note from the pocket
oh yeah and i had written a note but he
didn't know that
and it said
dear lou
um
this is ernie
um you will not remember me but about 20
years ago you were playing a comedy club
in vancouver i thought it was ottawa i
think it was vancouver okay it's
vancouver i don't think these important
details
let's not do city dropping no just names
this is why it made sense to me no but
it i'm saying for the audience they're
not gonna that's the story would be so
much better in ottawa
but
but but it could have been ottawa oh
[ __ ] so anyway
it said you know and and the you know
this is in the in the
late 70s early 80s the comics on the
road he was a single guy at the time
because you won't remember me but i was
a waitress at the so and so comedy club
and listen we're two consenting adults
and we had some time together and i
never wanted to burden you because i
felt the response the responsibility was
mine
and what you are staring at now are the
fruits of that evening
about two and a half years ago i was
diagnosed with breast cancer
um i treated it it was in remission
funny right
and then eight months ago it returned
and if you are reading this note and
looking it into ernie's eyes
i i don't know a better way to tell you
this
this is your son
yes that's what that's what happened so
he comes back to the phone
and um
he goes howie
i go what he goes
you're not going to believe this
it's my thought this is my song what
it's my song
he couldn't even say it like what are
you saying lou he goes my son my son is
here i go what the [ __ ] you talking
about he goes i have a son
i have a son
i have a little boy named ernie and he's
here
he's here and i'm going what the [ __ ]
are you talking about there's no [ __ ]
way i don't have time for this it's one
o'clock he goes i'm not [ __ ] with you
i wouldn't [ __ ] with you about this uh
ernie is my son he's i go [ __ ] i
don't even believe there's a kid here
put him on the phone
so he goes
ernie my son ernie
come here talk to this man so he puts
the kid on i go okay ernie
here's what i want you to do
here's what i want you to do when you
get off the phone he knew it was me and
mark was waiting in a car down down
around the corner
when you get off the phone count to five
and go
nobody loves me
nobody cares for me and then run as fast
as you can out of the apartment across
the whole building
down there and at the corner you'll see
the red
uh a car that's your uncle just get in
the car and go away
so the kid gets off the phone lou gets
back on the phone he goes what am i good
my life changed like that what am i
gonna do
i hear in the background the kids scream
nobody loves me
nobody cares for me
and then he ran out the door i hear
the phone drop and it's lou going
i love you i want to care for you
and the kids running at one o'clock in
the morning is running out of the
apartment along the whole balcony and
there's a grown man in his
underpants chasing after an
eight-year-old little boy going i love
you i want to care for you
you know
anyway what happened is people in the
building saw it and i think they
complained and he was afraid he was
going to get thrown out of the building
and that's the straw that broke the
camel the kid got into the car and drove
away he got in a lot of trouble with the
building that was the straw that i
recall it being a lot longer than him
just coming in for five minutes it was
he was there why does that matter yeah
he was there for 15 minutes no he was
there for what appeared like hours to me
and i could not figure out what because
i didn't know i i mean it was really and
then the kid ran
and i thought and i ran after him saying
i love you and i want to care for you
i love you my son ernie
i love you my son ernie
i love you ernie
my son ernie i love you
[Music]